salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recessione finalmente tornati subito il
suo good
come vedete quest'anno voluto far
tornare verso 6 subet sud finalmente e
partiamo subito con uno dei migliori
l'uomo puma film del 1980 diretto da
alberto de martino è sì è una produzione
italiana non mi trattengo 8 e gustiamoci
questo capolavoro il film inizia con
dottor loomis
e lui e donald pleasance l'attore che ha
interpretato il dottor loomis nella
serie di halloween non mi ricordavo
fosse una fusione tra bob hoskins e
pippo franco
se c'è lui magari film non è poi così
trash surdo crediamoci interpreta cobras
un dottore guarda caso che trova una
maschera d'oro zecca che serve a detta
dell'archeologa che l'ha tradotta a
conquistare le menti degli uomini
incredibili queste reperto a tremila
anni di età e nasconde una straordinaria
tecnologia mamma e papà anno nuovo bebè
non se ne fanno più niente di te dove
l'ha trovata come l'ha trovata
ma chi se ne frega questo non è il luogo
né il momento per porsi questo genere di
domande ma qualcosa lo spaventa una
profezia narra che un solo uomo può
fermare tutto ciò faremo gli uomini i
nostri schiavi con questa maschera
domineremo tutto il mondo ti può
fermarci l'uomo puma
dobbiamo trovarlo leucci e l'ho detto
mettendoli in penombra perché sono il
cattivo ma siccome la profezia non era
chiara su chi esattamente fosse questo
l'uomo puma il prof inizia a
defenestrare uccidere la gente che
assomiglia alla descrizione avrebbe
potuto usare qualche altro metodo per
capire se una persona ognuno puma o no
chi può che ne so e lo schifo di
maschera che controlla la mente delle
persone
sai non potrebbe essere utile invece di
uccidere persone a caso facciamo la
conoscenza del nostro vero protagonista
tony l'antropologo arrivi tardi ho già
comprato una tuta di seta per cosa per
battere il record di caduta libera
sei un incosciente lo sai quanto ci
vuole a venir giù dal trentesimo piano
meno di due secondi se capitate in come
te la cavi imparino a bonanni non solo
secondo
mi fa morire come se ne va facendo una
risata da priolo assoluto tra l'altro ma
il doppiatore e tonino accolla perché ci
assomiglia ma non sono riuscito a
trovare informazioni a riguardo
mi alleno per la risata di eddie murphy
toni è in ritardo per il suo turno di
lavoro al museo di storia naturale
che c'è si sente male
mi capita solo quando percepisco un
pericolo si dimenticavo questo film
ciucciato fuori perché in quel periodo
tra film e cartoni animati i supereroi
stavano spopolando e non potevamo non
copiare quello che andava di moda in
quel periodo mi ricorda qualcosa pero
youtube vero cioè ma tornando al film un
uomo misterioso sta pedinando toni wow
complimenti per st mimetizzato in modo
da non farsi scappare subito
ati ha sgamato subito mi chiedo perché
sarà il fatto che assomigli vagamente ad
andre the giant con i capelli della lego
non si sa
ok ci sono due cose in questa sequenza
che mi turbano
1 l'effetto caduta tra lamento visto un
green screen così orrendo un mio
applauso va a chi nella produzione del
film è riuscito a dire porca paletta
sembra veramente che stia precipitando 2
basta defenestrare la gente immaginatevi
un attimo se il professor xavier degli
ics man per cercare i nuovi mutanti
invece di usare cerebro professore a un
minuto un attimo sto per testare i
poteri di questo giovane mutante
no non era pronto per diventare un
supereroe
ovviamente toni cadi in piedi ma viene
subito inseguito e raggiunto
tu sei l'uomo puma e l'ha inseguito come
un maniaco sessuale e buttando giù la
porta a spallate soltanto per
sussurargli quello di pulsante se lo
dovevi ammazzare che faceva tornato al
museo incontra la bionda di inizio film
che lo invita a casa sua per un incontro
antropologico e di ci stiamo incontrando
in un sogno
no non credo
allora è proprio vero sono caduto dal
terzo piano
innanzi e pirica no sono un po
nell'orgoglio odio dal profondo del mio
cuore quando due personaggi si parlano e
uno di loro rivela qualcosa ma senza
spiegare nulla per bene sembra di essere
tornati a guardare lost o se vi state
ancora chiedendo come funzioni
esattamente quella maschera azteca del
prof
sentite qua puntandola verso la persona
che vuoi conquistare crea una testa
finta della persona che vuoi controllare
su un altare attaccata degli elettrodi
con cui puoi dare ordine non vuol dire
una merda ma è fighissimo
non voglio assolutamente estranei tra i
piedi
poco prima di andare all'incontro appare
di nuovo il bestione il suo nome è
famiglia un sacerdote azteco che
conosceva il padre di tony e gli rivela
che anche lui era un uomo cuma e che per
diventarlo deve indossare una cintura
toni non ci crede e mi chiedo come mai e
scappa alla festa al quale mostra è
sfuggita e stavolta fa quasi pena mi
scusi ho avuto un incidente d'auto
niente ti crea resterà ma perché non
glielo dice se non crede di essere
l'uomo puma perché non dice l'agente
aiuto c'è un gigante con dei capelli
buffi che insegue perché 20
mi rimangio quello che ho detto poco fa
questo non assomiglia per niente arrosto
questo è lost
jack è successa una roba che cosa ho
visto l'isola negli occhi ed è stato
bellissimo
cioè
alla festa arriva cobras con i suoi
scagnozzi e toni è costretto a scappare
vadino spegne la luce e scopriamo uno
dei poteri del puma vedere al buio
devo dire che utilissimo il fatto che
comunque non si veda una letta riesce a
raggiungere il tetto vadino gli passa la
cintura e lo spinge a fare un salto
della fede e poi salta vuoi che mi
ammazzo rete lan e ora arriva la scena
più bella non del film non di tutti i
film non del mondo ma dell'intera
esistenza passata presente e futura
una scena che è talmente bella da aver
generato l'intera umanità il cosmo e
tutte le altre stelle
sto dicendo cose a caso ma non importa
finché nella vita esistono scene come
questa mala
toro si sbagliava questo è il vero
valhalla lui che vola palesemente appeso
a dei cavi con uno sfondo a caso
perfetto la musica poi sembra quella che
potresti trovare in una pubblicità di
prodotti alla soglia non riesco a
piegare figliolo
non c'è nulla di cui vergognarsi fai
come me può madre usa su dias burger
e questa la dedico a tutti quelli che mi
scrivono ho visto un film talmente
brutto che mi sono fermato dopo 10
minuti
no questo è il motivo per cui film del
genere vanno visti tutti dall'inizio
alla fine
potessi perdi ti delle perle che
accadono una volta ogni mille anni non
riesca ad andare avanti con il video
dopo cotanta bellezza
proviamoci vadino gli spiega che i suoi
poteri sono controllati dalla mente ma
dai
pensavo dalle dita dei piedi
l'invulnerabilità fa parte dei miei
poteri
no una semplice pallottola po a
uccidermi se allora guarda guarda bene
che salto faccio il più grande salto che
uomo puma abbia mai fatto per andare
dove sbagliarmi da qui i dialoghi solo
tanto troppo stupidi avete presente
quando si dice qualcuno fare finta di
recitare shakespeare di polo rosso loro
verso per questo è il problema
ecco qui fanno sul serio toni parte
all'inseguimento di cobras che lo porta
in una trappola ma lui ma lui con i suoi
nuovi poteri contrattacca tornato da
mascella d'acciaio viene portato nel suo
nascondiglio
uno schifo ma come fai a dormire la
super come si dorme non è importante
come si è svegli
sono diventato saggio leggendo le frasi
dei baci perugina aung concentrerà tua
mente sulla sacra immagine del dio po ci
sei riuscito fratello si bene so che
stanno dicendo così pagamenti importanti
per la trama ma io non faccio altro che
pensare toni assomiglia a un sacco ai
modelli di prodotti per capelli
just for men
e come se il volare non fosse abbastanza
può teletrasportarsi andando attraverso
le pareti
cazzo succede o di nuovo confuso
dolcificante con la ketamina no si
scopre che per teletrasportarsi deve
riuscire a focalizzare qualcosa che ha
già visto e questo è giusto perché non
puoi teletrasportarsi in un posto che
non hai mai visto infatti lui si
concentra sul suo amico e si
teletrasporta nel suo camion
tra pochi minuti vedremo come tutto
questo diventerà inutile si fa regalare
un ricevitore e ritorna dal saggio che
però viene rapito dagli uomini di cobras
o anche i buchi vi trovano cobras non
sapeva dell'esistenza di vadino
tantomeno il suo nascondiglio toni
intanto fa a brandelli nemici sa già che
lui usa i poteri del puma come gli
artigli il teletrasporto e il volo
classico boom a originario del sud
america lui insieme all'uomo gatto di
sarabanda con il potere di indovinare le
canzoni e l'uomo dog capace di
allontanare i clienti potrebbero creare
i vendicatori con i superpoteri di
dubbia utilità li ho vinti riesce a
salvarlo quindi fanno partire il piano
per catturare cobras il nostro eroe
inizia col teletrasportarsi dalla bionda
che sull ubicazione della maschera stack
a 2
se vuoi teletrasportarsi facilmente solo
focalizzandoci su una persona perché non
ti te nei trasporti da compra
direttamente questo è il genere di
cagate che succede sempre quando metti
determinati poteri in una storia come i
poteri del viaggiare nel tempo se non lo
si sa utilizzare bene si creano casini
ma la donna è controllata da cobra se
stesso quindi non riesce a rivelare la
posizione grazie al trasmettitore
comunque raggiungono la villa di cobras
e chi vien da chiedere ma che cazzo gli
servono i poteri se poi usa il
trasmettitore che si prepara al suo
diabolico piano invitare a casa sua per
un caffè con biscotti le alte cariche
dello stato e usare la maschera per
controllare le loro menti non solo
induce anche la bionda ad uccidere toni
fallendo ovviamente
ma
cosa successe quel qualcuno mi spieghi
qualcosa e di laurent cobras a una sfera
di energia che lo protegge con le teste
di manichino dentro fatto sta che riesce
a controllare la mente di tori e gli fa
perdere i poteri
io distruggo i tuoi poteri
sul saldo avuto i poteri per mezz'ora e
già li perde sembra una di quelle
peggiori puntate di smallville e compra
solo induce giustamente al suicidio meno
male che và dihno egli per salvarlo per
cercare di resistere
ripeti con me un uomo e un dio ogni uomo
è libero non devi pensare a nient'altro
e ora che ci penso bagnino lo ha aiutato
tantissimo da quando è diventato un uomo
puma se oggi fosse stato lui sarebbe
molto più e più volte ma i poteri non
sono ancora finiti o o no si scopre
infatti che può fermare il suo battito
cardiaco e fingersi morto
esco scusa quando un uomo di potrebbe
mai servire un potere del genere a rho
mi serve aiuto arrivo il tuo soccorso
grazie uomo puma grazie ora che non ha
più i poteri come riuscirà a salvare il
mondo
semplicissimo eva digno a salvare il
dopo aver stordito è legato toni va
rinnovata cobras minaccia di farsi
esplodere riesce ad entrare in casa sua
ea distruggere le teste di manichino
peggior supereroe di sempre si libera
soltanto quando ormai cobra si è rimasto
da solo
beh che ce l'hai li massacrano top6
inutile un uomo bubba il mio culo se
riuscite fanno scappare da una botola ea
fargli prendere un elicottero è dunque
teletrasportarvi e disperato lo insegue
volando per catturarlo
abbiamo visto che desideri trasportato
da into the net abbordabile torni
gottero puoi tiene trasportarti a fianco
a lui tirargli un pugno e catturarlo
ormai sei finito propria squadra
muore veramente dopo tutto il casino per
catturarlo lo fai schiantare morire non
è riuscito a fare neanche questo perché
ricordiamo la chi ci sta seguendo è
stato fa degno a fare tutto ma mentre il
saggio è costretto a ritornarsene nel
suo paese d'origine a bocca asciutta
toni si cucca la bionda o ingrato non ti
meriteresti neanche uno yogurt scaduto
figurati la gnocca la super eroi di sta
cippa su come le più forte di te
e quindi con mio grande rammarico vi
dico che il film finisce qui perché io
avrei potuto guardarlo all'infinito e
bellissimo spero che vi sia piaciuto
perché ripeto
devo andare